hey what's up guys and welcome to a live
introduction to PvP in blood-borne I
usually script my content I don't
usually narrate live so I'm not that
used to it but I figured I want to
describe what I'm doing in real time and
I know that'll make it harder for me to
PvP but I do feel like it'll be worth it
so here's our first opponent the first
thing you're going to notice about PvP
in this game is that healing is
incredibly easy to pull off as a result
we're going to want to shoot him with
our pistol while he's at range and
trying to heal and just generally try to
stay as close to him as possible so here
we go he's buffed his weapon so I should
do that too
so right now he should be looking to
heal and you can tell so I'm going to
make sure he doesn't get the chance to
do that so there you go
but Bourne PvP so that's enough live
commentary I really want to tell you
everything I've learned about the PvP
thus far and also tell you about my
first impressions of it so to start you
might be wondering how invading works as
soon as you have ten insight you'll be
able to by the sinister resonant Bell
from the insight vendor in the hunters
dream
whenever you ring this bell in the
overworld it's going to attempt to form
a connection with a bell maiden in
somebody else's world so your next
question is what is a bell Maiden well
basically she is the link between you
and another players world your Bell
interacts with the Bell that she's
ringing and you can only invade a player
who has her in their world as far as I
know there are two ways to make her
appear the first most common way is by
ringing the beckoning Bell to invite
helpers into your world whenever you
summon help using the beckoning Bell you
consume one inside point and also summon
a Bell Maiden into your world for
example this is her location in all the
Arnim and a part of this is finding out
where she is when she spawns because the
Bell maiden as I mentioned before will
draw invaders meaning that whenever you
initiate co-op you're pretty much
begging for invaders to come and get you
so your objective when you initiate
co-op is to find this spell maiden and
killer if you like and hopefully you do
this before you get invaded by someone
the second way to summon her is more or
less a confirmed rumor at this point
there are reports that whenever you ring
the sinister resonant Bell to invade
somebody else's world there is a chance
that you can summon a bell maiden in
your own world so basically whenever you
ring the bell to invade it also might
make you open to invasions from other
people and this is a really clever thing
because if you want to invade someone
then you're perfectly okay with someone
invading you as well right and if this
happens it's better because it's
to be one-on-one it's going to be a
jewel and you both want to be VP moving
on in some areas the bell maiden will be
there from the very beginning no matter
what for example the one in nightmares
frontier is always here regardless of
whether you summon help or not and that
is why I've been here all day so I
suppose you could call this a designated
PvP area because invaders will find it
very easy to find your world it's the
best place to try and invade if you want
one-on-one fights instead of fighting
ganks banks and fighting people who are
engaging in co-op I've been enjoying
this so much just fighting people in
nightmares frontier having so much fun I
mean I'm sure you can see from the clips
how cool the PvP looks in this game it's
so different and fast-paced and hectic
and frantic I loved it and I found that
I never run out of insight either so
when you ring the bell to invade people
it doesn't use up the insight point when
you invade them and die that's when you
lose the insight point but if you invade
them and succeed you gain an insight
point so think about it this means that
if you have a better than 50% win ratio
then you can indefinitely invade people
which is really awesome I've just been
spending all my insight points that I've
been getting on fire paper because I
love this flaming great sword how good
does it look the last thing I want to
say about the bell maiden is that as it
stands I don't think there is a way to
invade someone who doesn't have a bell
maiden in their world so you're going to
either be killing people in coop or
fighting people who are in the PvP zones
of the game and once you've killed the
boss of the level I don't think you can
summon or get invaded anymore so moving
on to what I think about the PvP in
regards to the moment-by-moment gameplay
let me show you this clip where I in
vade two players in coop earlier I
mentioned that it can be super difficult
to kill people who are dead set on
healing and co-op is an enhanced version
of this problem each of them could
potentially have 20 blood vials which
can make for some seriously drawn-out
fights this fight lasted 20 minutes and
I've heard about people having fights
that lasted an hour or more the combat
of blood-borne is incredibly fun
fast-paced don't get me wrong but you
should expect some seriously long fights
in the early game at least and that's a
point I have to make I'm only halfway
through the game and these are my first
impressions I think it's fair to be
worried about healing or other concerns
about the PvP but it's definitely way
too early to make judgments because who
really knows what the late-game is going
to bring and the fights right now
they're not that bad just because
they're drawn-out doesn't mean they're
unfair if you aren't play your opponent
that just means he'll go through his
blood vials faster than you will so you
can still outplay him healing isn't
unfair in that regard all it does is
draw the fights out a lot and the
interesting thing about that is since
I'm invading halfway through the game I
haven't finished the game the guy I'm
invading hasn't finished the game and he
wants his blood vials he doesn't want to
waste them in PvP so while it does draw
out the fight
there are definitely drawbacks to using
them and the length of the fight itself
depends on how cowardly the people you
fight in co-op are so many people I
fought were chickens like look at these
two guys these two guys barely
progressed through the level because
they knew I was waiting for them behind
enemies and they knew that was the only
way I would be able to kill them if they
agro the enemies and you'll find this
happens often if someone needs help with
the level chances are they're probably
not that great of a player or a bit
cowardly in general that's just the way
it is so the best way to kill people in
co-op is to engage them while they're
fighting the enemies of the level and
once you do this the fight gets
incredibly fun and frantic enemies do a
fair bit of damage to other players more
than you will anyway and staggering them
while they fight a group of enemies can
make it seriously hard for the player to
sustain that much damage it's also the
only chance I've ever found myself
having to throw numbing mist at them
numbing mist is essentially the Lloyds
talisman of blood-borne they're stopping
opponents from healing you can see this
guy frantically trying to heal and
wondering what's wrong with his heal
button that was funny now in my
experience they're fairly easy to dodge
which is a huge problem because if the
enemy realizes you're about to throw
they'll be able to avoid it with ease I
mean look at all these throws where my
target moves a little bit and they still
miss there's one clip where he's like
half bent over and it goes over his head
it's ridiculous it should be way easier
to hit with these things I don't think
there's ever been a game where it's been
valid to throw these at the opponent and
that's a problem because you should have
the ability to stop healing for a short
amount of time or something like that
and so far I've found no way to buy
these from a merchant so you're limited
to the amount you find out in the world
but that again might change in the late
game so until we learn a little bit more
about late game pvp you've just got to
assume that your early PvP matches are
going to be a fight of fatigue you're
going to be trying to run out of blood
files after your opponent does rather
than overpowering them but hey that said
it's not impossible to overpower people
and maybe this will be a more valid
thing in the late game or maybe I'm just
not very good at the game my strategy in
PvP is to just stay as close as I can to
the opponent and shoot them whenever I
think they're going to be going for that
heal
usually I can chip them down until they
die or at least I can stun them so I can
get closer to them and continue my
assault and that's an interesting thing
too you can actually trigger a visceral
attack by timing your gun shot with
their heal they kneel down and then you
can go and start your post so once I get
good maybe this will be an option for me
or maybe in the late game weapons will
just do a lot more damage and it'll be
way easier to overpower people but as it
stands as you go through the game it's
very easy for them to heal oh and
speaking of visceral attacks you can
still initiate them the same way you
would in PvP when that enemy attacks you
and this is a really common thing it's
even better than parrying was in Dark
Souls because when you parried in Dark
Souls and you failed you still would
have got hit but if you shoot someone
and try to parry them in this game even
if you fail you still staggered them so
there's no real punishment if you fail
but while parrying and visceral attacks
is more popular I tell you what's not
more popular backstabs
you're not going to see many back stabs
in PvP I mean think about it you have to
fully charge are
and you have to hit them in the back so
unless they're afk that's not going to
happen off and I said this a thousand
times but the late-game pvp could look
completely different so if you're
subscribed I will make a video on that
when I feel confident in my beliefs
about it so look forward to that and
that's basically it that sums up my
thoughts I'm enjoying the PvP so much
I'm enjoying the game so much and I'm
really happy about the opportunity I
have to share it all with you guys ever
since I started on YouTube just playing
the game has never been enough all I
want to do is share my experience as
well and I want you guys to experience
that feeling as well which is actually a
bit of a hint for some upcoming videos
that I'm doing sharing your experiences
with me and the channel and with other
people is going to be a big thing so
really hope you look forward to that I'm
soaking to get it started but yeah
that'll come soon when I'm ready and
I'll talk to you guys later
thanks for watching
you